fabiana genies has high hopes for the
coming months she's fighting to win the
German women's handball championship
with her team BTW kind and then she
wants to win Olympic gold on home soil
with the Brazilian national team I have
clear priorities intensive training and
the matches I'm playing now in the
German championships will help me go
into the Olympics in top form fabiana
genies has been part of the Brazil team
since 2003 and is now the captain of the
side the team won the world cup in 2013
their biggest ever success and an
example of how hamble is growing in
Brazil the country's overall Olympic
squad 117 medals at the Last Summer
Games in London they want to beat that
total this year in Rio Brazilians have
always got most of their joy from
football now we're trying to bring them
happiness as well I'm sure Brazil will
put on a brilliant Olympics event for
the cbse no Brazil the Brazilian
government's has invested heavily in
sports in the build-up to the games but
fabiana says she can only continue
playing professionally because of her
contract with bt came so success for her
team this August would just a little to
Germany